In this video,
we'll discuss the concept
of under complete and over
complete hidden layers in
auto encoders, which will help us
identify another weakness of a deal.
Two encoders as we've defined it so far.
So now in this video we'll talk about
what's the impact of the size of the
hidden layer.
So the output of the encoder,
the size of that factor,
what's the impact of choosing different
values for that size when we're training
20 quarter in terms of the types of
features or that type of information that
we'll learn about, uh,
our input distribution,
well distinguish two cases.
The first case is known as
the under complete case,
so hidden layers under complete if
it's smaller than the input layer,
if it contains less elements,
uh, then the input vector.
So in that sense we see that the
hidden layer has to compress the input.
It has more,
it has less bits to a store.
The what we would like to be the
same information as the input layers.
So there'd be fewer bits in the
representation of that vector.
Then the representation of that vector,
just by the fact that this is a
larger vector and then that factor.
And so because of that,
when we're training the autoencoder really
it needs to learn to compress and it
needs to learn to compress or it
will be trained to compress well, uh,
only inputs that are generated
by our training distribution.
So all the inputs that are
present in our training,
a set aren't going to be welcome pressed.
And because a d a hidden layer has,
because it's lossy compression, we have
to remove certain bits, uh, quote unquote,
then it means that there are certain
factors that he won't be able to
reconstruct perfectly.
And so really in the under complete case,
we have the nice thing
that the auto encoder,
we'll learn to learn good features for
the training distribution in the sense
that these are going to be these hidden
units here are going to be a good for
being able to reconstruct inputs that are,
uh,
that look similar to what's
found in the training set.
But it's going to be bad for other
types of inputs, say a random input.
So if we put the random vector here and
our training set does not contain random
vectors, then um, because
this is a new example and, uh,
because our training layer
are hidden layer has, uh, uh,
less capacity than the
original input space,
then it will possibly not be able
to reconstruct perfectly. Okay.
Because it will have to
lose some information.
And presumably that's information that
in this case it's important to have that
information to encode that vector,
but not in this case.
Now what about the other
case is when the encoder,
the hidden layer is a
bigger than the input layer.
So then we say that we're in the over
complete case and now in this case,
then there's actually no compression
that's required by the autumn quarter.
Uh, and in fact, if you think about it,
each had an unit could just copy an
individual element of the input vector.
Uh, so, you know, this could go here,
this here, this here, this here, uh,
and so on like this.
Uh,
and then there even be some hidden units
that we'd be left and would not need to
be a use because by just copying each
of these elements here into the hidden
layer,
then we could just put back
the information into the
reconstruction and get a
perfect reconstruction.
So you think a little bit about,
you can try to think a little bit
about how you could parent tries no 20
quarters.
So it's that it does this in
the over a complete case and uh,
and then if we do this, then we think
about the value of that representation.
Well, really it's, it's, it has no value.
It doesn't extract anything
that's meaningful. Uh,
it's just copied the
information element by element.
So I'm really feeling that as the input
say to some other classifier is going to
be equivalent to feeling
just the original input. Uh,
and yet if say we're interested in
extracting features for linear classifier,
we actually want to have a lot of
features Alania class fire as a very small
capacity.
And the more features we give it,
the more opportunity we give it to be
able to distinguish between different
classes. So that's actually in a sense
of bug in the irregular or twin quarter.
And also this partly explains why we
weren't not learning some particularly
meaningful features when
we saw the example or we're
training an autoencoder or
numbness a, it could just do something
very similar to just copying the,
uh,
um,
copying the pixels into individual,
separate a hidden units, and then
reconstruct them back into the, uh,
the reconstruction output. And so
that's another problem with, you know,
tone quarter where in the
over complete case, uh,
it's actually not encouraged
to learn anything meaningful.
So in the next videos,
we'll see two ways of addressing that
problem and such a way that we actually be
able to extract some
meaningful features for, uh,
be getting good results in terms, for
instance, of our classification task.